my name is Chris McCaffrey and I'm a
junior studying history in English at
Hillsdale College I'm here to introduce
mr. Fred Segal Fred Segal is a senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute and
the scholar and residents at st. Francis
College in Brooklyn he is a contributing
editor to city journal and has been a
fellow at the Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton and a professor at
the Sorbonne and the Cooper Union for
science and art mr. Siegel was a senior
adviser to Rudy Giuliani's 1993 mayoral
campaign he has written for numerous
publications including the Claremont
Review of Books the Public Interest
commentary The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times the Weekly Standard and
The Washington Post he is the author of
numerous books including the future ones
happened here New York DC LA and the
fate of America's big cities the Prince
of the city Giuliani
New York and the genius of American Life
and most recently the revolt against the
masses how liberalism has undermined the
middle class please join me in welcoming
mr. Fred Segal thank you
oh and thank you for having me here at
Hillsdale I've never been here before
and I'm thoroughly enjoying myself we
were all hoping that Bret Stephens would
be here tonight unfortunately I can't
promise I'll be as interesting as Brett
he's just as you know it's just terrific
I want to talk tonight about Henry
Mencken
HL Mencken some of you will know who he
is some of the younger people won't let
me just say to people who don't know who
he is
he was enormous ly consequential he was
the most influential intellectual figure
of the 1920s he dominated the 1920s and
I'll talk a good deal about making my
the argument you'll see me make here is
that Menken is alive today that Macon
has had enormous and profound influence
but not I suspect where you would assume
I would argue that HL Mencken the
curmudgeonly mr. Menken is the very
intellectual fount of contemporary
liberalism and I'll explain before I do
that I should I should point out that
Hillsdale is one of the few colleges
I've been to where HL Mencken is still
taught John Miller but I don't know if
John's in the audience tonight professor
professor of journalism has the students
read Menken which i think is just
marvelous
there are two ways of thinking about
making one is on the basis of how Menken
sounds those who read read he will know
what I mean on second ways the substance
of Menken what I'm going to try to
explain is how both those people who
emphasizes sound and those people
emphasize the substance have gotten him
wrong the often astute literary critic
Joseph Epstein who was mentioned this
afternoon recently wrote that is one
contribution of the English language was
that his creation of the term virtue
Kratt virtue Kratt is a synonym for
liberal the virtue Kratt is a sentiment
synonym for someone who thinks that by
thinking good things their acts
elocution Airy therefore they have done
good things so liberal is not you're not
liberal by virtue of what you do but
liberal by virtue of what positions you
take the buttresses point
Epstein quoted from the famous French
brothers in the 19th century the goal
chords and this is what they said they
said literate literary arguments over
who has better taste arguments about art
involved who has the better eye but
every political argument born boils down
to this I am better than you are
the American needs them only in America
in peculiar ways who brought that style
of thinking to these shores was HL
Mencken you will be surprised to know
that the famed journalist who coined the
terms Bible Bible Belt and boob huazi
was one of the fount of modern
liberalism he was as he crowed to all
who would listen a very superior person
and he said this in many ways many times
though well the self-educated Menken
expressed himself through a vast
vocabulary and the very sound of his
writings are a pleasure
but the sheer volume of his publication
has assured they still read to the
current day he stopped writing in 1949
he had stroke died 1956 in 1977 three
volumes of his letters were published
three volumes in 1987 other letters were
published in 1990 his Diaries were
published the diaries cause us some
something of a sensation because Menken
who was strongly against lynching and
many who called for the Jews of Europe
to be brought to America engaged in
certain kinds of petty social
anti-semitism and racism in his Diaries
this was a tempest in a teapot in 2010
the library of America republished his
prejudices the prejudices with a
collection of the articles the short
columns that he wrote that he was best
known for that was 1222 pages and it
wasn't inclusive in 2014 his three
volumes of water biography were reissued
with an additional 200 pages of
unpublished material the man literally
didn't have a thought that went
unrecorded or unwritten he wrote about
30 letters a day in addition all all his
other writing and here's Menken who
loved to insult his audience so long as
there are men in the world he clowned
99% of them will be idiots the mob the
mob man who I described as the boobas
americanus must believe in something and
it must be something indubitably not
true the one thing he can't get down is
a fact now the problem with that is that
when Megan came to write about the
Scopes trial he got most of his facts
wrong and I'll come back to that his
writing on scopes the widely accepted by
liberals
we're that of a fabulous and I would
recommend to you though anyone is
interested in the Scopes trial a book by
a man named Edward Larson called summer
for the Gods it's a brilliant historical
account of what happened in Dayton
Tennessee contemporary journalists
deploy is marvelous one-offs like his
famous quote no one ever went broke
under estimating the intelligence of the
American voter the Jonathan Gruber
affair however suggest that the clever
phrase is well wide in the mark the
American voter wasn't fooled by the
Obamacare melee the only people were
fooled by where Gruber's fellow
academics so today there are two kinds
of thinkers who write about the sage of
Baltimore those who write about a sound
and those who about right about its
substance there are those like the
essayist Joseph Epstein who thirty years
ago
I hope he's changed his mind found
Menken's assault on platitudes and
platitude Marion's a wonderful Menken
word platitude Ariens entertaining
Epstein asked who would Macon could
refer to cliches as quote the old
wheezing of a melodeon melodium x' and
old-fashioned accordion or refer to hot
dogs as cartridges filled with the
sweepings of the abattoir the
slaughterhouse or to college teachers as
the average drover of undergraduates
Menken's unmistakable prose had said
Epstein a fine writer himself and
orchestral power I agree with that based
on strong verbs exotic nouns outrageous
adjectives and a confident cadence as
well as wide learning the influential
critic alfred case and some of you have
heard of also taken by the sound and
minkins prose suggested less charitably
that it resembled not an orchestra but
WC Fields playing the tuba making
dismissed opinions he despised and they
were numerous here are some of the
phrases he used Buncombe Bosh Tosh
balderdash blather blog father wrote
Emmitt on and on when you read Macon you
better have a dictionary head at hand
Macon memorably described the writing
style the famed early twentieth century
economist Thorstein Veblen as quote
there were a relentless disease a sort
of progressive intellectual diabetes
this last phrase I like a leprosy of the
horse sense more contemporary essay on
on on Menken written by Russell Baker
you remember it as the humerus for the
times now retired the title of the piece
that that Baker wrote was called a
genius for contempt he Baker wrote much
of the pleasure of reading Menken comes
from the burble of his words words even
when the content is trivial or annoying
and of course most of the time Macon is
doing his best to be annoying someone
for all those who luxuriate in the
furrows of minkins dithyrambic
denunciations of democracy that's my
phrase but I was it's a tribute to make
and athere ambach denunciations
democracy and the peasants and yokels he
ought loved to refer to American people
as peasants and yokels there are those
were taken not with the sound but the
substance of minkins writing and there
was despite all all the furor and splash
considerable substance making remains of
fugle Minh one of his favorite turns few
women model for philosophical free
marketeers to tend to look behind beyond
is amusing animate versions to the
Nietzschean core of his writings
referring here to the German philosopher
Nietzsche so even they avert their gaze
from the full impact of Lincoln's
Germanic German Ophelia Meghan wrote the
first book on Nietzsche published in the
shore
19:08 the book was more than exposition
it was notes mingkun biographer teri
teacher and i should say on this since
2000 alone four biographies of Menken
have been written that doesn't count the
many biographies were written before
2000 that's how large a figure he was
and continues to be the book was more
than exposition notes Menken biographer
Terry Teachout it was autobiography in
disguise and I'll come back to that
theme when sometimes when Menken is
writing about nietzsche he's really
writing about himself and by the way
this is just an aside Minkin was a
distant cousin of the German Chancellor
Otto von Bismarck who created the modern
German Empire the modern German state
now you stop here for a second the
period
Menken lives in is the period of the war
of English succession you never heard
that phrase when our referring to here
is it was clear by the end of the 19th
century that England was in relative to
decline it was in relative decline
compared to Germany in the United States
that the age of English Empire was big
was beginning to fade
and so the great great question at hand
was who would succeed England as the
dominant power the Germans thought they
should succeed the Americans didn't
think about this at all like many of
Menken's and Meyers Joseph Epstein
describes Menken as having been harassed
during World War one for being
insufficiently patriotic but that defies
the facts making was a German
nationalist and as such both a
palliative of anti-americanism
and a champion of the kaisers armies in
World War one I'll come back to that
Menken's Nietzsche and writings on World
War 1 on behalf of Imperial Germany have
been ignored by the enthusiasts of both
the sound and the substance you rarely
see reference to them opposed to
American intervention and the Great War
on the side of the Allies Menken had no
objection to war per se
drawing on Nietzsche's conception of the
will to power he wrote war is a good
thing because it's honest admits the
central fact of human nature a nation
too long at peace becomes a sort of
gigantic old maid
what Macon opposed were British and
American attempts to restrain German
militarism not war per se as his
apologist would have it the war notes
making biographer Fred Hobson focuses
thoughts and created a clear position
here's Menken 1914 I too like the
leaders of Germany had grave doubts
about democracy it suddenly dawned in me
somewhat to my surprise he's being
disingenuous here at the whole body of
doctrine that I've been preaching was
fundamentally antioxidant and if I had
any spiritual home it must be in the
land of my ancestors when World War one
started i began forthwith to whoop it up
for the kaiser and i kept up that
woofing so long as it was any free
speech left and he refers here to the
repression of World War one now when
most people try to give you an account
of liberalism they either refer to
progressivism with a new deal and a book
I wrote revolt against the masses which
I have copies outside I'd be delighted
to sign I try to show that modern
liberalism culturally was created
neither by progressivism nor by the New
Deal what was created in the aftermath
of World War one in a response in part
the Woodrow Wilson's repressions during
World War
when you couldn't speak German with
sauerkraut every thought thought this
talked up his Liberty cabbage and so on
and so forth in 1914 before the u.s.
entered World War one
Macon wrote there's the title the essay
the mailed fist the armored fist and
it's profit the profit being Nietzsche
in which he presented Germany as a model
for the United States now Macon argues
that in the 1870s Nietzsche was right to
mock Germany but when you read Menken on
Nietzsche in Germany in the 1870s you
realized Magnus actually writing it
about himself in America in the teens
and 20s so here's what here's what he
says about Nietzsche in Germany in the
70s no epithet from Nietzsche was too
outrageous no charge was too far-fetched
no manipulation or interpretation of
evidence was too daring to enter into
his ferocious indictment he accused the
Germans substitute Americans of
stupidity superstitiousness silliness of
a chronic weakness of will for dodging
the issues a fatuous barnyard and green
green grazing contentment clumsy and
unintelligent government and worse yet
he argued Germany was guilty of a
slavish devotion to Christianity the
spiritual dyspepsia and a plural
mysticism this is this is Menken this is
making on America he sees this and Metis
writings about Germany in the 1870s
you'll see in a second why this is
significant if I go around the bend and
I hear someone hitting the floor I'll
stop but according to Macon by 1892 when
Nietzsche wrote his masterpiece thus
spake Zarathustra an enormous change had
come over the German scene vast new
energies have been unleashed not by the
old Younker aristocracy of the barracks
and the court but by a new era
ah cracy of the laboratory the study and
the shop Germany at Sergey argued to the
forefront of the world this is what
Menken wonder for America and our stock
recei of the lab exports shorthand
Germany insisted Menken had transcended
the anglo-saxon world this knew him the
student German Germany said was the
democracy but not like American
democracy
it wasn't founded on the romantic theory
that all men were equal I'm quoting
Menken now uh-huh it was free of the
tape of ma ba cracy minkins name for
democracy it was empty of soothing and
windy phrases on the contrary it was the
delimited aristocracy and the Athenian
sense of democracy of intelligence and
strength of superior fitness and it
created a superbly efficient ruling
caste
that's what Menken wanted from America
wanted for America and I won't go into
it now but I talked about how in the
1920s other strands of liberalism wanted
the exact same thing so while political
liberalism was created by Woodrow Wilson
by the New Deal cultural liberalism the
libido of liberalism was created in
these years right after World War 1 by
Menken and others who rebelled against
wilsonian ISM during World War one
the new Germany said had taken what had
been the hardiness of a single class the
Yonkers and turns it into a hardiness of
an entire people war one is Menken saw
it was the culmination of Germany's
Nietzsche and inspired ascent to power
to prove his point making quoted xerath
rooster bear with me this is the one
long quote this is from Nietzsche 1892 I
do not advise you to compromise and make
peace but to conquer let your labor be
fighting and your peace victory what is
good good is all that increases the
feeling of power the will to power power
itself and man what is bad all that
proceeds from weakness what is happiness
the feeling that power is increasing
that resistance is being overcome not
contentment but not more but not
contentment but more power not peace in
any price but war not virtue but
efficiency the weak and the botched must
perish the weak and the botch must
perish perish that is the first
principle of our humanity and they
should be helped to perish I am writing
for the Lords of the earth this is
Nietzsche now this strain of thinking is
not peculiar than each year Menken I'm
sure you've all read HG Wells no matter
no matter your age some of you read
wells his outline of history some of you
read The Invisible Man is science
fiction fantasy but you've already HD
Wells HG Wells was a great eugenicist he
too wanted the weak to perish liberalism
is not what people assume it is
liberalism it's strong strains of social
Darwinism and eugenics toothed elements
I won't get into tonight well what I
will get into is the idea of a superior
caste of a ruling aristocracy that
should run the country and here I'm sure
some of you are anticipating Jonathan
Gruber
thus concluded Menken writing about
nazarath rooster with Germany's armies
on the march in 1914 Jo and he becomes
Nietzsche Nietzsche becomes Germany
Menken cheered on the sinking of the
British ocean liner the Lusitania by
German submarines the sinking which 128
Americans lost their lives he applauded
this in print he was a courageous man of
nothing else he dismissed the slaughter
in Belgium as beneath his concerns while
writing about the greatness of the
Kaiser and Germany's general Emil
Ludendorff and during woke during the
war Ludendorff became an effect leader
the fact that President Kaiser of
Germany and another was adoring and none
other was Atlantic ABS essays he wrote
about the authoritarian genius of
Ludendorff in fighting a Nietzschean war
and made it clear that Macon's concerns
for freedom were secretive when he was
when he was presented with what he saw
as beautiful Authority now I'm not gonna
talk to tonight at all about the 1930s
communism but liberals of the 30s also
thought they saw a beautiful Authority
and Stalinism Menken thought he saw and
the Kaiser and Ludendorff a beautiful
authority that deserved to be obeyed the
essay on Lewton Ludendorff counseled
that what Megan wanted was not so much
freedom so that the citizen wouldn't be
subject subject to arbitrary Authority
but rather freedom because he didn't
want the uber mentioned the over man to
be constrained by ordinary people
he liked unregulated capitalism not
because it gives the poor a chance to
rise because it allowed the superior men
to have their way unobtrusive here's an
irony making it was a strong opponent of
censorship
and courageous at times monitor
censorship was saved by an act of
self-censorship he wrote an essay called
title the essay was after Germany's
conquest of the United States now the
only reason we know this essay exists is
because of letters between Menken and
the Atlantic it was withdrawn from
publication what's odd about this is
Menken published every stray thought he
ever had this he withdrew from
publication and it saved him and I say I
says was some certain guy his papers are
at the Enoch Pratt free library in
Baltimore I spent time there I've spent
time with the curator and I try to track
down his is there an existing copy there
may be two existing copy of this but he
couldn't find it and I certainly
couldn't find it so now we jump to the
origins of liberalism the cultural
origins of American liberalism were
rooted in the early 1920s when Menken
his close colleague Sinclair Lewis I'm
just curious how many people have read
Sinclair Lewis's Main Street how many
people under 50 of read Sinclair Lewis's
Main Street one two three four you need
to read Main Street not because it's a
good read or expressed as a good novel
it's it's neither but because it's so
some oh it was a political earthquake
and described as such at the time the
early twenties were described by Alfred
kaizen as the age of Menken when the
clowning curmudgeon expressed better
than his peers the post-war
disillusionment with Woodrow Wilson in
particular in America with gent in
general the post-war writers like like
Edmund Wilson the heirs of Randolph born
have unfortunately perished in World War
one we're critical not of Germany in
World War one they were critical of
American democracy
they blamed American democracy for the
war these writers I'm referring to the
writers who defined liberalism of the
early 20s these writers wrote Malcolm
Cowley who was the chronicler chronicler
of this generation quote seized power in
the literary world almost like the
Bolsheviks in Russia that's exactly
right
I'm thinking Yvette's you all read F
scott Fitzgerald F scott Fitzgerald
Sinclair Lewis Edmund Wilson and on and
on
this generation defined American letters
then and ever since
but Menken's article been published
about the desirability of the German
conquest of America it's hard to imagine
even the politically tone-deaf literary
critic Edmund Wilson would have insisted
in 1921 that quote Menken is the
civilized conscience of modern America
Wilson wasn't alone
New York Times thought him the most
powerful private citizen in the country
he was beloved by campus newspapers the
campus smart said one college newspaper
called him the guiding light of
undergraduates that says a lot about
undergraduates in 1926 walter Lippmann
called him the most powerful personal
influence on this whole generation of
educated people but Lippmann shrewdly
went on to note that Menken often
couldn't tell the difference between
ignorance and evil Menken created a
liberal demonology out of the Scopes
trial it lives with us today the play
inherit the winds supposedly based on
the Scopes trial it's based on Frederick
Lewis Allen's account of the Scopes
trial which was based on minkins account
so we have Macon's fabulous account
frederick lewis's louis allen's account
and then the play what we end up in
contemporary world there's no idea what
actually happened at the Scopes trial
the trial might be surprised to learn
was initiated by the ACLU
looking for a test case looking for a
way to put itself on the map it only
been found that a few years earlier it
was not found about the locals as Menken
suggested nor the local locals mean
spirit the mean-spirited boobs he
depicted the locals supported the trial
as a matter of boosterism for their town
of Dayton Tennessee no one that ever
heard of then at Dayton Tennessee
Lynette never heard about it again the
idea was this was going to put the town
on the map it would draw all sorts of
reporters all sorts of interest it did
but not in the right way scopes was well
treated and well liked by the people
making the truck describe this cretins
and supposedly buffoonish William
Jennings Bryan quote making the idol of
[ __ ] dumb was a well read world
traveler who had debated Darwin's
origins of species with Henry Fairfield
Osborn the president of the Museum of
Natural History Bryan was indeed
completely wrong about evolution but as
criticism the social Darwinism Menken
subscribed to was to prove preaching
with the coming of the Nazis when mink
winced to do when Bryan died suddenly
after the trial
making gloden quote we killed the son of
a [ __ ]
he wasn't a nice man in 1926 the year
after the Scopes trial Macon published a
book you've been working on for many
years it was titled notes on democracy
it proved an embarrassment to most with
the exception of the Kaiser who sent a
note from his exile in the Netherlands
praising the book a government by yokels
was making argued sure to be a scandal
and a farce the u.s. he said is such a
scandal in such a farce democracy maked
explained for the umpteenth but far the
less far from the last time was a
conspiracy against
the superior men the superior men had a
monopoly he said of higher virtues of
the higher virtues but makin zap efforts
demonstrated than the subject of
democracy as opposed to his own three
volumes of water biography making it
full-length was far less compelling then
as then as an intentionally then ended
in his intentionally comic columns and
his columns as crotches were hidden by
his descriptions of histrionic preachers
preaching presidents overwrought golf
enthusiasts political paul truly that's
one of his favorite two terms Paul truly
or Paul Truths a poltroon is a political
lowlife a political hack and operator
Shelly silver a friend side that he wish
had Menken hadn't written the book
because it reveals too much about him
carried along by the animus to the anti
alcohols the prohibitionists by the way
I don't know how many people realized
that the prohibitionists were by and
large left-wing the Socialist Party
supported prohibition the progressives
supported prohibition prohibition was
not as in as you get in modern modern
demonology with post-modernism it's
really not any reason to talk about
academia cept that a few places like
Hillsdale but prohibition is not what
you think it was it was a mistake but it
wasn't a mistake of right-wing the
right-wing group was he in mangas terms
Mankins star ascended to the heavens the
1920s but it descended rapidly in the
1930s when is the stain for FDR and
indifference to the suffering of the
depression cast the shadow over his once
incendiary wordplay Menken's inability
to describe Hitler as more than quote a
preposterous montebank and a second-rate
Klansmen hurt him and the public
standing making along with Sinclair
Lewis not only the author of Main Street
Elmer Gantry but another book that if
you haven't read it's worth reading it's
a book called it can't happen here
it's reissued every few years Paul
Krugman refers to it during the Bush
years he kept on suggesting that it
can't happen here in other words fascism
will come to America the bizarre thing
about it can't happen here that the
fascists in America were the members of
the Rotary Club how many people have
been to a Rotary Club meeting
can anyone thinking of anyone less like
a fascist now Rotary Club meetings might
be boring when they're talking about how
to raise money for from muscular
dystrophy but fascism Sinclair Lewis
didn't have a clue as to what he was
talking about Lewis conceived of
homegrown fascism as the expression of
the Rotary Club run amok simile Menken
seemed to think that Hitler was merely
Babbitt run amok in the 1920s Macon was
considered a leftist yet without
changing a jot or a tittle to his views
in the 1930s he was the claimed as a
rightist what was continuous was as the
stain for democracy in the American
middle class that is the boob huazi the
diaries Macon began to write while
politically embittered in the 1930s were
defamed when published in 1990s for the
supposedly racist and anti-semitic jobs
they allow the politically correct to
mock him as a beer-swilling bigot a
hypochondriac and a small-town mama's
boy he was all of those things he was
also a brilliant writer but we redeemed
them for liberals was his hostility to
the boobs censorship Christianity in
America in 1991 when after 25 years
under lock and key the diaries were
published the arch liberal John Kenneth
Galbraith jkg
who had his own doubts about democracy
when those Diaries were published
Galbraith felt compelled to defend
Menken and not just JK
gee Louis Auchincloss the biographer of
Waltons biographer among other things of
walter Lippmann the great Ralph Ellison
John Hersey Norman Mailer Arthur Miller
Arthur /nu jr. william Styron kurt
vonnegut not an important set of writers
felt compelled to come to minkins
defense making received a simile
stentorian defense and a khadeem
although in his own time he'd mark
professors as priestly pedants what was
this about
I'll come to that in April third on
April 13th 1945 noted Galbraith the day
after FDR's death making quipped and his
characteristic style FDR at every
quality that morons esteem and esteem in
their heroes thus the demigod seems to
be in the making but wrote John Kenneth
Galbraith here's the problem today the
most ardent supporters of FDR and one
trust of racial tolerance and decency
regularly turn up as the most devoted
admirers and defenders of Henry Mencken
why why were so many liberals and thews
about making since Macon had nothing but
the stain for FDR a new deal which they
adored first thing that should come to
mind is the very terms left and right
don't mean a lot I'll come back to that
here's Galbraith with those who read him
long ago remember was was was
wonderfully explosive liberating attack
on the conventional stuffy world what he
said was perhaps sometimes wrong what he
made us believe that you could take on
establish few points what he said about
Roosevelt released us to say what we
wanted to say about Herbert Hoover and
William Randolph Hearst the making
liberation this is Galbraith a kind of
greatly different difference the target
was closely again to that of Thorstein
Veblen
I'm sure Galbraith hadn't read Menken's
mockery of egg of Evelyn leave aside
Menken's mockery of Evelyn's nearly
impenetrable prose style I don't reckon
I recommend in reading Veblen unless you
want to abuse yourself galbrace account
to use one of them Incans favorite words
is balderdash shirley Galbraith doesn't
mean to suggest that Hoover and Hearst
hadn't already come under withering fire
from the New Republic the nation and the
New York Post among other publications
they had he's making absolutely no
since Galbraith comes closer to the mark
when he explains quote I have cited
perhaps a hundred times his definition
of conscious Minka that is maintance
definition of conscious is quote that
inner voice that want warns that someone
might be looking it's a good line
whatever Macon's prejudices the word
making himself used to describe as
essays he would said Galbraith the
tremendous liberating force but more
important though Galbraith never had
Menken's honesty on the subject was that
like Menken Galbraith believed although
for different reasons and government by
superior men and he Galbraith was very
sure that he was one of those superior
men and here we come to the Grothman of
the issue despite Mankins love for the
Kaiser whose autographed picture hung in
Menken's bedroom and appreciate signed
by the Kaiser quote in in appreciation
for the mailed fist and its profit
despite spiked makin sometimes casual
rate racial aspersions and I'll sylheti
to active government the same man must
was much beloved by today's libertarians
and conservatives did Morris save as
close contemporary Sinclair Lewis to
create the cultural foundations of
contemporary contemporary liberalism
than any other individual now we repeat
that Menken and Lewis are the cultural
founts of contemporary liberalism Menken
style and the substance of his disdain
for the work of day American so
permeated post-world War two liberal
culture it's impossible to imagine it
without his influence taked white
McDonald some of you no doubt of Reds
white McDonald he's a wonderful III knew
the white he was a wonderful writer it
couldn't think straight but he was
wonderful at a wonderful wit like Macon
MacDonald was never able to come to
grips with Hitler or anti-semitism he
wanted the United States to remain
neutral at World War two he became one
of the most influential left-wing
journalists intellectuals after world
war ii did macdonald europe explain
McDonnell has its Hitler's but we have
our Rotarians he's harkening back here
the Cinco Luis it can't happen here
McDonnell wrote about Henry Wallace the
Communists back candidate for the
Progressive Party in 1948 and a few of
you are over old enough to remember this
he really hit it because when when
MacDonald wrote about Henry Wallace he
sounded like Menken and Coolidge and
Harding and here's here's Dwight
MacDonald Wallace land Wallace for those
of you don't know was that a fact though
can be candid of the Communist Party in
the 1948 elections 1948 lectures at for
candidates Harry Truman Thomas Dewey the
governor of New York Strom Thurmond and
Henry Wallace Strom Thurmond ran as the
Dixiecrat Henry Wallace ran as the
leader of the Progressive Party and to
put this into perspective George
McGovern adored Henry Wallace well let's
go back to 1948 quote Wallace land is
the mental mental habitat of Henry
Wallace plus a few hundred thousand
Raider regular readers of the New
Republic the nation and then a newspaper
that no longer exists called p.m. it is
a region of professional perpetual
verbal fogs caused by the warm winds of
the liberal Gulf Stream coming into
contact with the Soviet glacier its
natives speak Wallace ease the base
provincial dialect Anthony Lewis some of
you must no doubt remember Anthony Lewis
for 25 years of columnist of the New
York Times Lewis was a self-proclaimed
socialist although he admitted socialism
didn't work it didn't matter he still he
still supported it Anthony Lewis
columnist for The New York Times I think
from 1978 to 2003 Anthony Lewis ed
described Menken as a personal God
in the fifties the liberal standing
standard Barrack John Kenneth Galbraith
melded political state ISM with cultural
mechanism by mock mocking free-market
economics and the Christian mores of
Main Street as the conventional wisdom
like hom jakey jkg developed a
rhetorical device passing past which
passed himself off as an understanding
of society more importantly for would-be
intellectuals growing up in the 50s
suffocated as they saw it by phony
adults makin was the anticipation of JD
Salinger the anticipation of Holden
Caulfield and if you young people
haven't read a Catcher in the Rye
you need to read us you can understand
your parents now richard hofstadter
columbia historian twice Pulitzer
prize-winner was sometimes known as the
second Menken I won't go into details as
to why is the second Macon
suffice it to say there's an appendix in
the upcoming paperback edition of revolt
against the masses which is on which is
about Hofstadter as the second Menken
but making wrote a very famous essay
excuse me Hofstadter wrote a very famous
essay called the paranoid style in
American politics
I'm curious undergraduates how many how
many of you read the paranoid stall in
American politics so a fair number of
you've read it it's an enormous Lee
important essay what Hofstadter did is
what mingkun did he turned political
categories into psychological categories
so he he demeaned Goldwater supporters
as headcases he allowed and and hostile
like Menken was a fine writer he allowed
the work of style to do the work of
substance if you haven't read you're a
little older and you haven't read the
paranoid style read it because I can
guarantee you every journalist I know in
Washington has read the paranoid style
and it's quoted at least three
four times in his life I'll be it quoted
it mistakenly because by the offside I
wrote it in 1965 but the end of the 60s
off cetera changed his mind what
happened was the Columbia campus had
been taken over by SDS use and lo and
behold Hofstadter discovered that people
who were psychologically problematic
were on the left as well as the right he
was stunned in the late 1960s Norman
Mailer appropriated the main Canyon
trope to write off the regular folk as
the wad in 1978 Nixon Nicholas von
Hoffman the libertarian new leftist
wrote a book called make-believe
presidents illusions of power from
McKinley to Carter which updated minkins
accounts of presidents since Grover
Cleveland as bastard's
rulers and bloggers today minkins the
subject assumptions have been so widely
internalized among liberals there's no
need to name naked when the editors of
slate has everyone know that online
magazines slate when the editor of Slate
disturbed by criticism of president
obama wrote an article in town entitled
about an article entitled down with the
people or when MIT professor jonathan
gruber
was caught on tape bragging about
stupidity of the American people it's a
siddha tea set which allowed Washington
to sell the American people Obamacare
but of course they didn't sell Obamacare
he wasn't sold Harvard professors
however were an enraged when they
discovered that their premiums were
going up by a few hundred dollars
judging by the 2014 election returns it
was not the public but Gruber's fellow
academics who were deceived
more recently Daily Beast writer Michael
Tomas key and in LA Times columnist
Michael hits Hiltzik explained at the
public public affairs to embrace the
glories of Obamacare was due to the
inked election
intellectual inadequacies of the
American people then again if you
believe these two colonists you believe
Obama's past former pastor Reverend
right that the problem in the inner city
is the problem of middle class
mindedness the problem Detroit if you
didn't know it was people a to
middle-class minded that's positively
bizarre Menken's great achievement is
they taught successive generations of
American liberals how to be
narrow-minded while projecting an air of
superiority let me repeat that because
it's the core of his continuing
influence how to be narrow-minded while
projecting a core an excuse was
projecting an air of superiority the
writers who held the sound of minkins
writings mrs. and mrs. German Ophelia
and Nietzsche anism the Libertarians
grass the grass through Nietzsche nism
but failed to see that Macon's ideal was
a statism of sorts in which superior men
like himself ran the show liberals like
Gayle Galbraith hailed by academia came
the closest to continuing the spirit of
minkins anti-americanism but only after
they brushed aside his deep disdain for
the New Deal last paragraph ironically
Menken the iconoclast has had as
attitudes adopted by the priestly caste
that wants to shame and rule us today
sixty years after his death HL Mencken
is a continuing albeit malign influence
on American politics and culture thank
you
Thank You mr. Siegel after the Q&A
session will will have a book signing
mr. Siegel has agreed to sign his new
newer book they revolt against the
masses how liberalism has undermined the
middle class and those be available just
over here about the stairways please
raise your hand and we have a few
minutes for questions
looks like we have one starting in the
back and then we'll come forward sir
thank you very much for your time today
I want to go back towards where the end
of your speech where you talked about
how Metin help make people on the Left a
little more narrow minded my question
goes to you Howard do we as
conservatives in the journalism spectrum
actually go towards responding to that
from a perspective this is going to be
convincing towards a majority of America
thank you sir I I think you should work
on something refreshing evidence-based
journalism I think if you base your
journalism on evidence you'll convince
people of your arguments with the art if
the evidence work if it supplies a
convincing argument it will supply a
convincing basis for the public to
follow those arguments there's no
substitute for evidence you know people
forget that all of Obama's how should we
describe it lying about about the Obama
about about Obama care was all visible
in 2010 it was there an unconventional
in congressional hearings it was there
in articles written about it it wasn't
picked up but over time the facts came
came to the fore and that that's
generally what happens just give me a
brief example for reasons I won't go
into I follow events in Yemen there's no
good reason to do that it's a it's a
bizarre place what's what's actually
what's called north and south there is
actually west and east but nothing makes
sense in Yemen there's no water four
months ago the president announced Yemen
was a great
tactical success Yemen is falling apart
right now evidence comes to comes to the
fore sometimes too slowly as in the case
of Benghazi but it does come to the fore
everyone agrees with everything I said I
was I'm Moochi about the American
Americans and America yeah first of all
I would suggest you you you you read the
mail fist in its profit it's it's it's
readily available just online at the
Atlantic it's clear when when Menken is
writing about nici's actually writing
about himself the book i nietzsche was
autobiographical the essay is is
autobiographical so when when he uses
the same phrase it puts the same phrases
in Nietzsche's mouth that he may he make
it has used himself and other articles
we can draw the conclusion that he's
he's using Michi to advance his own
views which are not so different cuz
he's it's it's complicated because he's
in part formed by Nietzsche
yes my quiz even they stand us believing
a little more please please stand up you
explained a little further how the
publication of Lincoln's Diaries revived
his reputation that wasn't quite clear
enough I don't think it I hope I didn't
out but that didn't come across the way
it's not so much it revived as continued
his reputation he wrote so much and he
purposely planned that every 20 years or
so additional additional trove of his
writings would be released he literally
wrote 16 hours a day
he wrote 30 letters a day how could you
possibly do that so there are three sets
of letters released in the 70s then 1990
the diaries are released the only reason
the diaries produced a kerfuffle is
because they weren't politically correct
and whatever you want to say about
Minkin he wasn't politically correct and
so he wasn't an anti-semite he wanted to
be wanted after you are to rescue the
German Jews he wasn't a racist he was
vehement critic of lynching it was a
lynching on the Eastern Shore of
Maryland in the 20s he wrote about it
brilliantly I mean I think Meck making
it was a malevolent influence but he
wasn't a racist or an anti-semite
he was just sharp tongue but the diaries
produced this backlash and so Galbraith
and all these other authors felt
compelled to rush to his defense but it
didn't revive his reputation his
reputation we really never went away
it's it continued I mentioned Paul
Krugman before a corpsman did it two or
three columns on it on Menken s themes
by way of Sinclair Lewis it can't happen
here the rotary is marching again George
Bush is leading us in the direction of
dictatorship it's too stupid to believe
to be believed but it's it speaks to a
continued a continued influence
you mentioned that prohibition back then
over here
oh you mentioned that prohibition back
then was left-wing and you're looking
for someone to disagree with you so I
just want to observe that academic dean
of Hillsdale College he Harold Mun who
many of the older folks may remember ran
for president in the United States on
the prohibition ticket four times back
in the and and by then it was certainly
not I just wonder what happened
III think you're right the prohibition
1919 was a cause pushed by progressives
and left wingers and it was it was a
straightforward reason too many working
men drank their salaries would go would
go from anyone's been in Pittsburgh
would know exactly what I'm talking
about
the steel mills are along the water the
bars at one street away and then the
homes are up or up the hill and so it it
wasn't blue knows it wasn't proves who
were pushing this the people were
worried that that working men were
losing their salaries and sending their
parent their families into poverty it
wasn't it wasn't as odd as it would
later come to seem and it became a
became a conservative cause but that's a
little later I didn't know by the way
the president of Hillsdale would ran for
president I have a family anecdote
involving Lincoln and I hope you can
provide additional context my
grandfather who was a doctor
committed suicide in 1938
because Lincoln had published two
articles that he wrote in the May and
September 1934 editions of the american
mercury he wrote those articles under
the pseudonym of George W Aspinwall and
in them he advocated publicly supported
medical care as I said he himself was a
doctor and because he was an ENT his
business was totally by referral Macon
promised not to release his name but he
did anyway and the result was that my
grandfather's medical practice pretty
much disappeared so he was a casualty of
lincoln's arrogance I would suggest I
wondered if you could say say if you can
provide any more information about the
american mercury perhaps you know about
that incident III I don't know about the
incident but the Menken was enormous ly
arrogant nothing else if not arrogant
the american mercury in the 20s
attracted a wide wide spectrum of
writers f scott fitzgerald for instance
published Sinclair Lewis wrote for the
american mercury by the 30s there's a
famous incident let me let me relate the
incident I think you'll see Menken is
invited to speak at a banquet for FDR
and he you know makes it clear he has
very little use for FDR FDR then
denounces Menken but it's in Menken's
language it's something making it
written about another politician and
making was sorely but he never really
recovered from this incident and he
became sour and bitter and the American
Mercury's suffered as a consequence and
it became less and less reputable I'm
sorry I can't tell you more than that
but if by the thirties
it wasn't the publication it had once
been that Menken did that is obviously
despicable III don't think there's
you know you can you can recognize
someone's brilliance in their talent but
not without thinking them moral or
decent or good I would apply that to
makin we have time for one more question
looking in the back here
yes mr. Siegel there was a movie made
four or five years ago called alleged
and it was loosely based on the book
summer for the gods it depicts Menken
exactly as you described him tonight I'm
wondering if you've heard of that movie
it's it's actually well-crafted but not
well known and it's a refreshing
alternative to the lies presented in the
in the other movie you talked about
concerning the Scopes trial thank you
III I never heard of this movie I now
want to go see it
I want you to get back to it alleged no
no that's fascinating because that book
the edward larsen book is a magnificent
piece of scholarship yes
could we get a microphone up look we
have an actress we've lost all control
now we'll take one more comment and then
we'll in the session i guess here we go
i urge you to go see it not because I
was in it because I'm easily forgettable
but it stars colm meaney as HL Mencken
he's brilliant and Senator go good luck
you know Fred Thompson as William
Jennings Bryan it is a wonderful little
film and this is an example of how the
left continues to sway the Hollywood
left continues to sway distribution
could not get a distributor for it could
not it is available you can rent it
because it does paint a rather
unflattering portrait of
what was your role in it I played mrs.
William Jennings Bryan I spent all my
time in a wheelchair thank you very much
and please join me again in thanking
Fred Segal